ciao maryners e benvenuti in questo nuovissimo videooooo
Allora, ormai è risaputo non esiste una festività senza un top e flop di Maryna quindi anche per questa pasqua
Mi sono sentita in dovere di proporvi. La mia pasqua top e flop
in particolare voglio raccontarvi due episodi di pasqua assolutamente flop
E uno di pasqua top
Iniziamo subito. La mia prima pasqua flop poi ce ne sono state altre
sempre uguali, adesso capirete perchè risale alle elementari
Alle elementari andavo dalle suore e dalle suore puntualmente a pasqua si faceva la recita di pasqua dove
Ognuno di noi di tutte le classi di prima seconda terza quarta quinta
interpretava un personaggio
inutile dirvi che
Se eri femmina il personaggio più ambito era chiaramente Maria
inutile dirvi che era il mio sogno fare Maria
Inutile dirvi che non l'ho mai fatta
perché
Mia mamma aveva avuto la brillante idea di portarmi a tagliare. I capelli da una scuola di parrucchieri
E chiaramente mi è capitata l'apprendista negata, proprio che penso che sia stato il suo unico giorno di lavoro dopo di che è stata licenziata
Mi ha rasato I capelli
E l'ho chiesto un caschetto sono tornata a casa coi capelli a spazzola
per colpa di questo taglio come dire poco femminile
La parte di Maria, non
L'ho mai potuta fare perché chiaramente c'era la mia compagna di classe coi capelli fino alle ginocchia che era perfetta e voi direte va
beh avrei fatto un'altra parte comunque carina
Volete sapere che parte ho fatto per tutti i cinque anni delle elementari
L'istigatrice del popolo e voi vi direte ma che parte; niente devo andare praticamente tra. La folla e
dire questa frase
votate barabba, votate barabba. Questo è quello che dicevo
Allora, sono andata a documentarmi perché non ricordavo più niente praticamente barabba
era come riportato in alcuni manoscritti, del vangelo
un ebreo appartenente al partito degli zeloti
Detenuto dai romani a gerusalemme assieme ad alcuni ribelli negli stessi giorni della passione di gesù detto. Il cristo e fondatore del cristianesimo
egli venne liberato, dalla folla ed è lì che interveniva io l'istigatrice della folla quindi praticamente io
Dicevo votate barabba per liberarlo, pensate che parte, cioè mi veniva detto che era una bella parte ed ero
Contro gesù quindi forse con me c'erano questi due
Appunto ebrei che dovevano uno dei due doveva essere
Crocifisso secondo me e quindi io dicevo voltate barabba per non crocifiggerlo quindi per per salvarlo e nomination
nomination vabbè chiusa questa infelice parentesi delle recite scolastiche
Passerei a una par con un po più recente ma non recentissima forse
sei anni fa
vivevo ancora a torino e praticamente
Non avevo programmi per pasqua perché ero in un momento un po di
ribellione non volevo passarlo con la famiglia e volevo fare qualcosa di alternativo
Volevo fare una pasqua un po alternativa perché come dice
Il detto natale con i tuoi pasqua con chi vuoi
Quindi io e la mia migliore amica dei tempi siamo guardate abbiamo detto ma cosa facciamo per pasqua?facciamo qualcosa che non fa nessuno
andiamo alle terme
Ecco
Rivedibile concetto di non lo fa nessuno perché vi
ricordo che tutte prese bene pronti a rilassarci a staccare dal mondo arriviamo alle terme c'era la coda fuori c'è una cosa mai vista prima
Tutti quell'anno a pasqua erano andati alle terme quindi non vi
consiglio di andare mai alle terme a pasqua. in quel periodo ero innamorata persa di un ragazzo quindi
ci sentivamo ogni tanto uscivamo però sapete quella situazione in cui comunque, non
Lui, non, si espone più di tanto quindi non puoi dire stiamo insieme a una frequentazione
Nella quale io ero completamente
sotto un treno
Arriviamo alle terme io mi metto il mio costumino eccetera eccetera, tra l'altro quando si fa le terme non, so voi ma
Io non è che mi mettono qualcosa sul più bello e metto costume che anche se lo rovino
sono tranquilla
Praticamente era un costume di merda e mi sono molto pentita di questa scelta
quando
appena entrata davanti a me
Vedo grazie a dio lui non mi ha visto
lui
Con una ragazza ed è subito panico
A quel punto ho detto allora o me. Ne frego anche se
sto rosicando un sacco e continuo la mia
Pasqua bellissima alle terme con altre 40 miliardi di persone la mia migliore amica
Oppure trovo una soluzione cosa faccio quando sui suoi social e vedo che lui l'aveva già detto  che avrebbe passato la pasqua lì
quindi mi sono fatta il viaggio
Paranoico del non è che questo pensa che io sia andata alle terme per
pedinarlo perché lì veramente era da
stalker numero uno
Quindi cosa ho fatto
Dopo aver pagato 50 euro di entrata di terme già
vestita come già col mio costumino pronta per tuffarmi nell'idromassaggio
Ho convinto la mia amica ad andarcene
Perché non potevo rischiare di fare una figura. Del genere non potevo numero veramente drammatica
Ma passiamo argomento top e
Sono, sicuro che di scendere una lacrima perché è un momento molto recente, si tratta
Di due anni fa e come tanti di voi già sapranno. Due anni fa
mi sono fidanzata con salvo
Cosa è successo due anni fa a pasqua è successo che
ero tornata a vivere momentaneamente a torino
Perché finita l'università non trovavo lavoro e quindi
Per non pesare appunto sui miei chiedo non pagare un affitto a vuoto me ne sono tornata a torino
è però ormai avevo tutti gli amici qua dell'università eccetera eccetera quindi venivo spesso qua a milano e
Dormivo a casa dei miei amici quindi anche quella pasqua proprio come quella. Del mio
della mia pasqua flop
Non avevo voglia insomma di passarlo in famiglia volevo un attimo
dell'ira milano magari di festeggiare fare qualcosa di diverso
E quindi ho sentito questo mio compagno all'università ex compagno sita perchè ormai l'avevamo finito,
finita che mi dice marina guarda se ti va. Viene anche su mia sorella
dalla sicilia siamo un po qua faccio una pasquetta qua sono anche degli altri amici che
insomma verranno a fare la pasqua qua siamo tutti insieme ci divertiamo dai vieni
Io non avendo tante altre opzioni perché tutte le mie amiche o lo festeggiavano con famiglia o con i fidanzati
Io come al solito ero single ho detto va. Bene ci sto
quindi prendo il mio treno vengo a milano
Prima cosa ti faccio ancora prima di posare le valigie e andare in centro a comprarmi dei nuovi vestiti
E li
Sento il mio amico che mi dice guarda c'è mia sorella in giro ben capito lei così vi. Vedete tornare venite a casa insieme
che con un mio amico
Ho detto va bene
Becco sua sorella in centro e mi accorgo che il suo amico
Io lo conoscevo già e l'avevo conosciuto in sicilia perché
la maggior parte dei miei
compagni universitari  veniva, dalla sicilia e quindi puntualmente
Io quasi tutte le estati scendeva giù e andavo a trovarli e quindi
Conoscevo anche comunque altri loro amici che non vivevano abbiano però scendevano come tutti I fuori sede in sicilia d'estate
E avevo conosciuto questo ragazzo in discoteca ma proprio tipo ciao piacere piacere fine
molto carino molto bello ai tempi era fidanzato io pure e niente quindi l'avevo conosciuto
Dopo tipo 1 2 anni non mi ricordo chi io lui non
Lo ammette però come era stato lui ad aggiungere mi, su facebook
Perché io proprio per principio odio aggiungere. I ragazzi su facebook cioè mi sento veramente una depravata quindi non. L'ho mai fatto
Accettavo solo le richieste di quelli che se mi sembravano carini lui appena. L'ho visto lo avevo già conosciuto
L'ho accettato e quindi da lì non è che ci sentivamo però sai ogni tanto
ci mettevamo un like tattico,
questa persona era salvo
Che quando lo vedo davanti però
anche tu qui
Bene, io non ne sapevo nulla infatti poi mi sono mezza incazzata col mio amico perché ho detto:" cavolo potevi dirmi che era lui, già lo conosceva
Nel senso potevo decidere se venire o meno da te per pasqua
magari non sarei venuta"
Ok
Detto questo lo vedo ci salutiamo eccetera eccetera
e poi andiamo a casa
Praticamente cosa è successo che per non mi ricordo cinque sei giorni a settimana
Abbiamo anche una specie di grande fratello perché eravamo, io il mio amico sua sorella
Salvo e I due coinquilini del mio amico e le rispettive fidanzate o comunque amici dei due con coinquilini
quindi abbiamo fatto praticamente un grande fratello in questi giorni di grande fratello
A pasqua pasquetta non mi ricordo. Ho avuto la brillanti le a dire ragazzi oggi cucino io
E già li dovevano aver paura
Perché ho detto già ci piaciucchiamo, io e Salvo, se lo prendo per
La gola come tutti gli uomi cadrà ai miei piedi
Cosa faccio, cucino mio piatto forte che sono gli gnocchi ai formaggi
non brucio la pentola?!
Cioè eravamo lì tutti che chiacchieravamo erano si stavano facendo un certo punto si chiama la puzza di bruciato immensa
Ha preso fuoco la pentola cioè con una figura di merda atroce niente
C'era creazione io facevo la timidina come sempre
Uno, due tre quattro giorni e poi noto al momento. Del primo bacio primo bacio è stato
molto molto molto molto difficile
Perché lui voleva baciarmi ma io: testina  testina testina e stra testina
Chiaramente devo fare un pò. La ritrosa non potevo cedere così
e
alla fine c'è stato questo primo bacio e praticamente
Nessuno aveva voglia di uscire vogliamo andare a ballare sai fare un po di night life nessuno voleva uscire
quindi non ho mai capito se l'hanno fatto apposta per lasciarci soli oppure se era veramente
Se non avevamo veramente voglia di uscire sta di fatto che io Salvo prendiamo la macchina. L'enjoy e ce ne andiamo
In un locale in corso como. in amicizia andiamo a bere
A parte che  io lo chiamavo amo perché io chiamo amo tutti
eravamo in macchina continuavo dire amo
Cioè lo trattavo un po tipo così tipo da amico perché io comunque gli amici li chiamo così
giuro
e ha
certo punto lui si gira e:"ma amo cosa"
Scusa io chiamo amo chi voglio io chiamo amo tutti quindi fatto andare bene
Momento amo. arriviamo in questo locale praticamente beviamo sai c'è la musica così e ci conoscevamo un po e praticamente ci raccontavamo
chi eravamo e
cosa volevamo dalla vita ad un certo punto, in questo momento filosofico si avvicina una
Che si pianta davanti a me ciè mi da le spalle e si mette a parlare con lui
chiedendole un accendino
in quel momento maryna doveva scegliere tra
Ucciderla
oppure fare la parte di quella che comunque non era interessata era con un'amica e non aveva alcun problema
Non l'ho uccisa chiaramente in quel momento
Io ho avuto la brillante idea digli già senti allora non
So come andrà a finire tra di noi magari non ci vedremo mai più però sappi gli ho proprio detto così
Se io fossi la tua fidanzata
Lo sai che in questo momento quella  tipa cioè avrebbe finito di esistere
E allora lui se ne sa ridere perché
Anche se gliel'ho girata così comunque era una mezza roba tipo che ero gelosa o no
Infatti non
so da dove mi è uscita però io sono così sono sincera quindi avrei detto cavolo se stavamo insieme queste si mette acqua davanti a
spostava diciamo senti in via ci sono anch'io cioè se devi chiedere un accendino lo puoi chiedere anche a me senza metterti davanti
Ok e B aria, non è il posto per te
Quindi già avevo capi... aveva capito già la tipologia di ragazza e diciamo che con questa uscita
Salvo ha iniziato a capire insomma che non mi era indifferente
anche perché dai miei comportamenti
cercavo di fargli capire
Che non era coinvolta
No sai facevo testina così c'è perché io sono un po diffidente all'inizio non mi sciolgo subito
Lì non so perché forse era stato l'alcol e l'ho buttata li
Tieni questo è quello che penso e io tipo ok!
Forse già dopo si sono pentita però
Ormai il dado era tratto
Quello che è successo dopo che è stato anche abbastanza
complicato ci stara dovrei fare un video lungo e raccontarvi tutto nei dettagli quindi
la chiudiamo qui e ne parleremo
Più avanti ve lo prometto che prima o poi vi racconterò tutto tutto tutta la storia
Detto questo spero che il video vi sia piaciuto come al solito se non l'avete ancora fatto
iscrivetevi al canale e
Cliccate sulla campanella vicino al tasso d'iscrizione per ricevere una notifica tutte le volte che pubblicherò un nuovo video e soprattutto seguitemi
Su tutti gli altri social
Instagram facebook e musical.ly io vi mando un bacione e vi faccio tanti tanti tanti auguri di una buona pasqua ci vediamo al prossimo miglior
adoro